biggest celebrity of the year the buzz
around this office is huge because
you're here how are you feeling thank
you
I wouldn't say I'm the biggest celebrity
well everyone's freaking out I'm telling
you they're very excited that you're
here today and so how does it feel how
are you doing I'm doing pretty good I'm
definitely not complaining with what's
happening in my life right now
and all the support I'm getting from
home is just crazy I've been getting a
lot of messages all over social media
and now being able to be home and
actually witnessed that in real life is
awesome that's great we saw you on Jimmy
last night and you were talking about
how one person you were hoping was going
to DM you or get in touch with you was
Drake and I understand that things have
changed today things have changed yeah
he did message me last night and I woke
up this morning with the biggest smile
on my face that's pretty awesome
I actually just replied to him I was
thinking really hard on what to say yeah
like what do you say back to my scene
for a little bit I hope you didn't get
to pizza I'm kidding but yeah that's
that's super cool I'm a huge fan of his
so that's yeah well I understand that
uninterupted flew you home in a private
jet yes tell me more and how much did
you love that and did you take in every
moment I did I can definitely get used
to that no need to worry about customs
and security just straighten the plane
and straight back home so that was that
was really nice of them so can we expect
like a documentary or something with
uninterrupted coming up like a life
stone maybe they tuned everyone day to
now speaking back to Drake is there a
song of his that you used to get pumped
up for any of your games or your matches
or is there another artist that you use
to sort of get yourself in the zone well
Drake is definitely on the top of the
list the past couple of matches I've
been listening to non-stop by him I
think it really pumps me up actually got
a question today in my press conference
on what song I was listening to before
the finals because there's a video on on
Twitter yeah of me like jamming out when
Serena is walking behind me and that
song was hot girl summer
meagan stuff yeah that's amazing that
song is really good I was kind of
wondering what were you doing right
before you are coming out what happens
what's your process or what happens in
the room before you come out I mean
everyone has a different process but for
you that day what happened well I kind
of got the sense of how I would feel to
play against her because of Toronto sure
but obviously New York was different
circumstances way different yeah way
different but I think I I handled my
nerves very well I like to meditate
before I go on court so I think that
really helps me stay calm and in the
present moment so I definitely did that
like I do every other match but no the
main goal was to just go into it like I
do in every other match I know it's hard
to they're not really gets this thing to
do it's it's hard to not focus on who's
on the other side especially when you're
playing an incredible champion like
Serena but that was one of the best
experiences of my life
and above all she's such a kind person
and I'm definitely gonna cherish that
moment for a really long time well
speaking of that since there was a
comment that she made after I guess was
during a press conference at people it
feels like maybe you're taking out of
context what do you think about all that
it's being made of that saying that she
didn't feel that she played her best
game or do you remember hearing that
about that I heard some comments on that
but I do agree with that I don't think
she did play her best tennis it's hard
to go into every match playing your best
tennis but you on the other side I think
I played I think I played really really
well yeah I don't think that loss is
gonna do anything to her because she's
still a 23 grand time Grand Slam
champion so I still feel like she's not
satisfied I still feel like she's going
to be striving for more and and I feel
like everyone needs to calm down and
stop trying to pit two women against
each other it was a sport you guys had a
great game that's true let's concentrate
on that right it was fantastic after
winning the Open you sort of transformed
into this celebrity I know you don't
feel it yet but I mean certainly we're
watching what's happening around
you are are you getting sparks of that
are you sort of understanding what's
happening or is it just I'll still feel
like a blur
no I am starting to feel a little bit of
what's going on I had the sense of that
after Indian Wells and Toronto but it
doesn't compare I mean I was on Jimmy
Fallon and now I'm here with you guys
I've seen you on TV so many times so
this is this is pretty awesome
well it feels pretty awesome to be
sitting with you I told my husband today
that it was coming to see you and he
said can we come I said no you can't you
can't come nobody's allowed to come you
just got a gig keep it cool so we're a
big big fan of yours obviously in our
household and everybody else's I was
really for sure
if there's any celebrity that you could
give tennis lessons to who do you want
to give tennis lessons to Jake yes why
not yeah we announced at the bridle-path
yeah that should I know that he's
watched many matches before so I feel
like he'd be down maybe one day I don't
know I mean I'm having a convo with him
right now so I think you need to make
that happen and I think that would be
pretty big that's big that's so good all
right what's the best advice that your
mom has given you dream big to get big
and don't forget who you are don't
forget your roots she's been telling me
that ever since I was a little kid and
that's what I've been doing I had I have
big dreams and had big dreams they're
slowly starting to become a reality but
I'm definitely I'm definitely not done
yet and don't forget your roots don't
forget who you are because your roots
are very important because that's who
made Who I am today and I'm beyond
blessed and humbled for that and to have
such amazing parents as well so that's
awesome yeah cuz they hold you down to
all of this as everything goes up like
that's right they don't treat me like
I'm anyone else but myself so that's
awesome
you